do you practice lucid dreaming i did  this in the past but uh i don't do it  systematically anymore i suspect it's  not functional for the brain because  it's in some sense like  inducing a trip in your brain similar to  taking drugs  because you are forming long-term  memories of things that you are not  meant to form lengthwise about  basically there are several modes of  learning one is a simple  uh  conceptual learning where your  perception doesn't change but the way  you relate your perception is changing  and there is another one where you  change the construction of reality  itself the way that you construe reality  and uh if you go to this level  if you also change the way you relate to  the environments you need to deconstruct  or suspend yourself and your agency and  the boundary between self and universe  and i suspect that's uh one of the  reasons why we have these dream states  in which we don't react  interact with reality itself